and all our friends are eating White  Castle and getting diarrhea oh I wish I  could eat White Castle and get diarrhea  being a vegetarian blows it doesn't have  to huh but into white castles all new  all vegetarian impossible slider whoa  try a totally meatless version of our  crave-worthy sliders and get ready to  ride the D train  [Applause]  it's glorious  [Music]  amazing taste but plant-based find out  what uses that unmistakable flavor and  subsequent diarrhea OMB for White House  Plus ask for no cheese and go vegan now  that's how you do diarrhea not the  all-new impossible slider from White  Castle while it meat eaters have all the  diarrhea warning your diarrhea will not  be blue  [Applause]